the political and media elites were in
their usual freakout mode after the
president spoke in Pennsylvania over the
weekend but while they were busy
obsessing over his pretty darn harsh
slam on NBC's Chuck Todd they missed the
real heat we put on tariffs and the
European Union's out there well we're
gonna put I said you can't go any higher
than you are anyway and they have trade
barriers we can't even sell our farming
goods in there they totally restrict us
so then they say we want those tariffs
take it off I said good open up the
barriers and get rid of your tariffs and
if you don't do that we're gonna tax
mercedes-benz we're gonna tax BMW you
want to have money I was look back at
the campaign trail it's awesome ever
since President Trump announced his
decision to slap tariffs on steel and
aluminum imports coming in to the United
States
Republicans on the hill have been trying
to convince him mr. president you're
wrong imposing these steel tariffs have
just interjected uncertainty into the
economy where just wasn't necessary
we're gonna end up costing more jobs
because of the tariffs that then will be
safe if I disagree with the president I
don't know of any trade war that ends
well that's not my reading of history we
want to limit as much unintended
consequences and collateral I can like
damage as possible how many of those
guys want Ohio Wisconsin well now
they're threatening to pass legislation
that would essentially nullify the
president's executive order when you say
all right let's have tariffs but let's
couple that with uncertainty that's
almost worse I mean those are dual
poisons to the economy
you know tariffs are awful tariffs
married--to uncertainty is probably even
worse we have some legislative tools at
our disposal I the question is of course
how do we get that to at the president
for a signature
I'm not happy with it because these
tariffs are actually going to be a tax
on the American citizens I think there's
a good chance that we will know if I at
least if I have my way well with all due
respect to Senator hatch like you
supported GATT you supported the TPP you
actually wanted to expand NAFTA and you
supported giving Obama fast-track trade
Authority senator hatch has been wrong
on every trade related issue in my mind
and now he and Jeff Flake both
soon-to-be retirees by the way are
suddenly the sledgehammers against
tariffs well once again we see that most
on Capitol Hill still do not get why
Donald Trump against all expert
predictions won the GOP nomination and
the presidency does Mitch McConnell and
Paul Ryan really believe that Trump
would have won Pennsylvania won Ohio and
won Wisconsin had he simply touted the
old globalist line that all trade no
matter what happens to the American
worker is good trade do you remember all
of the rosy predictions about opening up
our trade relationship with China it was
gonna be fabulous
they were gonna be freer and more free
press and I'll please no objective
review of what's happened since 2001
when we approved China's entry into the
World Trade Organization would say that
it's been a win for the US last year we
had the highest trade deficit on record
with China and by the way China has
brazenly ripped off our intellectual
property and they flooded the world
markets with an excess capacity of steel
and aluminum and what's happened well
you see those numbers there this is
driven down prices worldwide and driven
great US companies out of business by
giving massive subsidies to their own
industries the Chinese communist regime
let's not forget that engages in rampant
unfair trade practices and ends up
distorting the global marketplace
markets aren't efficient the way they
operate and its present the President
reiterated in Pennsylvania look Europe
doesn't have clean hands on the trade
issue either right now we're running a
hundred and fifty billion dollar trade
deficit with the EU and we know they put
up unfair barriers as the president said
to our agricultural products
massive subsidies to Airbus Europe has
been taking advantage of the United
States for too long both in failing to
meet its military obligations under NATO
and in the trade arena well Trump has
already forced their hands on the NATO
issue and the sky did not fall they're
actually contributing more to the
military now he's defending US economic
interests with these fairly narrowly
cast to aluminum and steel tariffs and
there's a lot of historical precedence
here as Pat Buchanan wrote in a recent
column from Lincoln to William McKinley
to Theodore Roosevelt and Warren Harding
through Calvin Coolidge the Republican
Party erected the most awesome
manufacturing machine the world had ever
seen and as the party of high tariffs
through those seven decades the GOP was
rewarded by becoming America's party
Trump's instincts on trade have been
spot on for decades as China has become
more repressive and US median wages
flattened for 15 straight years mainline
Republicans offered the middle class
more of the same we got more Wars more
immigration and more trade deals and the
GOP establishment and some of the
Democrats
well they heard the calls of Wall Street
they did not hear the voices of men like
this my father during the 80s he lost
his job due to imports coming into this
country and I want to tell you what that
does to a man with six kids is
devastating so I never forgot that
looking into his eyes in my household
what that does to a family you hear
about it but when you're actually
involved and it impacts you it's it'll
never leave you that should never leave
any of us
so now Donald Trump the only Republican
politician since Reagan who can actually
fill a stadium he's supposed to listen
to the same people who helped get our
country into the mess that he's been
trying to dig us out of the same people
by the way who couldn't see any of this
coming and still do not really see the
threat the China poses to the United
States to
freedom and yes to the free market I
think it's time for the party to unify
behind the president's vision and give
his policies a real fighting chance and
that goes for the White House staff as
well
president Trump needs key staff people
around him who support his America first
agenda of course there can be
disagreements that's all healthy and
good but his core principles of ending
illegal immigration creating fair trade
policies that benefit American workers
and stopping endless wars they have to
be sacrosanct with hope ex-con he needs
a communications director who's a real
seasoned strategist one who will clearly
articulate the President's message and
drive it home with great events like
that one that we just showed you from
the White House last week and voices
that reinforce his policies and yes that
requires daily message discipline and
real experience it's essential the chief
of his Economic Council should similarly
be someone who'll advances policies not
advocate against them Gary Cohen is a
really smart guy but he was never gonna
see the wisdom of protecting American
manufacturing he's the kind of guy who's
you know he's basically fine with every
Auto job moving to Mexico so long as it
benefits the bottom line of the
companies making the cars well the truth
is there really aren't that many US
economic nationalists around that to be
fair the president has enough people
though who disagree with him there on
Capitol Hill he doesn't need another
advocate for them in the White House
this is not a perpetual debating society
anyone working for the president needs
to know on these key issues the debate
is over the American people chose
Trump's vision so it's time to get with
the program and that's the angle